Hi.
And welcome to another Rawkode Bite
at the Rawkode Academy.
Today, I wanna show you why you should
always check your kube config fails
before you start interacting with your Kubernetes cluster.
Not a lot of people know this, but
a kube config
can actually delegate authentication
with your cluster to another binary on your
machine.
This is called an off provider and is
primarily used by cloud providers that want to
ensure the service account you're using to communicate
with your cluster is still active and valid.
They do this by issuing short lease tokens
that need refreshed on a regular.
As such,
kubectl can execute the g cloud command or
the AWS IAM authenticator command before reaching out
to your current context.
There's no restrictions on what binaries can actually
be executed.
So let's take a look.
First, let's run some harmless kubectl commands.
Before we get started, I just wanna do
an l s on my home directory.
All looks good.
Now, let's run get nodes
followed by get pods.
All looks pretty normal. Right?
Well,
let's actually take a look at what really
happened.
First,
there's some new fails in my home directory.
Uh-oh.
And if we take a look at our
kube config
and jump down to the off provider script
at the bottom,
oh, dear.
So while these commands are pretty superficial,
an attacker could execute
SCP,
RM, no preserve root, curl, or pretty much
anything else.
So
be careful.
Even when you download a Kube config from
someone,
always check the user section.
Major props go to Grace. Grace got their
first PR merged into the Kubernetes project,
and it actually adds a warning that will
be invaluable in making everyone aware of this
potential attack vector.
Grace,
thank you.
Everyone else,
be careful.
Have a great day.